good morning mercedes what you got for
us today
hello beautiful people good morning we
will start with a such
a cute tick tock video of a girl
and her puppy playing until she said
the magic word
oh my god oh mom
that's what i thought that's right the
pup did not stop
biting her hand and playing until she
yelled mom well that dog knows her mom
does not play around
all of a sudden very well behaved
and from from dogs to something that's
really
doggone hard math i wish
i had a hype man like this when i was
learning check it out
where's five hold it up
all right clap for king
clap again all right king show us number
one
all right clap for king
that's my boy
the video has been viewed more than four
million times on twitter
the math teacher was asking the little
boy to identify his numbers and his
classmates were so excited when he was
right especially that one boy who was
fist-pumping saying that's my boy it was
absolutely adorable
i love it i need him for the forecast
yeah
when the forecast is right yes yes
that's right
when the dog hears mom he knows he's got
to cut it out because
trouble's coming the boom is going to
get lowered right yeah
he was biting her and then he's heard
mom and said oh okay
it's uh time to stop i don't want to get
in trouble right he knows mom
mom means business mommy messing around
i love that